hello
friends and welcome back to rotten
tomatoes is wrong and a big welcome to
our new listeners i'm jacqueline coley
i'm an editor at rotten tomatoes where i
cover
independent film and awards and i'm mark
ellis i'm a stand-up comic rotten
tomatoes correspondent and
unlike two other people i'm familiar
with jacqueline and i's moms
do not have the same name yes they do
not
in the weirdest most insane plot twist
to ever
hit a comic book movie that's right kids
we're gonna be getting into it today
batman v superman the dawn of justice
and i think it's fitting
to have a versus episode as i have i
believe the host of verses
with me to help it mr mark ellis so i
want to just uh thank him for taking the
time
yeah you know what i really blew that
intro because i should have said i host
verses on rotten tomatoes but i just
went with the typical comic
correspondent route and i don't know if
it's versus jaclyn i don't know if it's
this show
but we've been blessed with great fans
that will write us emails
very passionate emails sometimes and
they say hey you gotta do this movie you
to do this movie and
today we give thanks to a lot of the
fans who wrote about batman v superman
but in particular
joseph plunkett hit us up and thank you
i'm not sure if your dad or granddad is
jim plunkett the super bowl winning
quarterback but either way joseph happy
to have you on board thanks for the
wreck
yes and we got it through our email
address rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com so please send them
and
as of this moment this is the most
requested for episode that we have had
so giving the people what they want the
big question is rotten tomatoes wrong
about the score
of batman v superman dawn of justice
it's got
28 percent rotten but 62
fresh audience rating but mark before we
dive deep
for those of us that may have forgotten
way back in 2016
uh what is batman v superman all about
all right so jacqueline you remember
back when superman made a movie called
man of steel
and he fought with zod and then he saved
the day at the end and metropolis was
what was free of the tyranny of possible
alien invasion
yeah well not everybody looked at it
like that and so
batman who lives across the pond in
gotham city
saw all the damage happening to
metropolis and is like oh no we got to
stop this
alien and then some other people sided
with him some people held up superman as
the hero that we
knew him to be and batman and superman
there's only one way to solve this it's
time to duke it out
and when you throw that into the vitamix
plus the fact that this
kid named lex luthor is starting to have
some ideas about being a controlling
little villain
and then we also have this mysterious
diana who's walking
around gotham and metropolis you put
that all into a vitamix and you say
oh my god what's going to come out an
abomination of a movie or is it going to
be the greatest comic book film in
history
not according to the tomato meter
anymore
man mark if the movie was half as good
as your synopsis i don't think we would
be here debating things
oh jack i know i'm getting i i put that
one early
getting it in early uh because uh we're
definitely gonna be talking about this
one i'm just gonna start with one little
punch and i swear i'm gonna play fair
lucy our producer has promised me to do
so so hey lucy how you doing
i'm doing well everyone it's i'm excited
to hear what you all have to say
also my mom's name is martha so this is
a very
personal movie for me i'm sorry oh
all right that's the uh the rare
nebraska martha
okay i thought they were only in kansas
well you know what i think what martha
what this movie did to martha
is was jack quaylen did to my name when
kean peele did that so
i feel for all the martha's out there um
is martha the mom version of karen do we
know that for a fact
don't do it i'm not gonna do that i
think our guests will be really upset
if we keep like we can't do these
zingers we gotta like let the rodney
dangerfield happen a little bit later
because we do have a huge
dc fan with us today i'm talking about
mr mike
kalinowski he's our de he's our guest
today and he is
as knowledgeable a dc fan as you can get
folks will also have recognized him from
showtime's black monday
cw's jane the virgin and so many more
when he's not acting or doing all things
dc you can watch him on the scn network
youtube channel
on their mandalorian review show with
that said
and all that funness let's welcome mr
mike
kalinowski how you doing mike good
morning good morning how's everyone
doing
it's doing okay i mean you were so
talented it's hard for me to get my
mouth around it let me just
i apologize for that i apologize for
that that
is a great line that i'm not going to
touch with a 10-foot pole god
listen listen why did you go there
i will say this about mike is that we
all know no not all heroes wear
capes right and mike proved that
not a few weeks ago jaclyn this man who
owns multiple batman costumes
decided on election day on tuesday
everybody's in line voting waiting to
cast their ballot
so mike who had already voted put on his
yes full
captain america suit got a bucket of
candy
and started handing out candy to people
voting and
he pretty much kept everybody in line he
kept everybody
safe he defended justice and that's what
he's going to bring to the show today
oh my gosh i am so about this i'm
sad that i didn't know that this existed
i would have loved to have seen it
i have been tweeted at by chris evans so
we're dating so this is
there you go fitting a fitting moment
it's absolutely not weird
but i did tweet about his butt and he
like really like responded and so
in my personal opinion chris evans
flirted with me
i'm like a poor man's chris evans in my
captain america costume i can't even
compete
being america's ass no no you you i'm
i'm sure
you did us proud and and i appreciate
you for like venturing outside to the
marvel universe i'm glad to see that you
still have love for them because i know
yeah i'm not one of these guys that does
both sides that pits each other against
each other i'm a fan of both
well i know you're a fan of this one as
well and i just so you're saying rotten
tomatoes is
clearly wrong i'm guessing you've got me
here for this reason and this reason
alone
i'm going to change minds change ideas
and everything about this you're
completely wrong
can i say are you so you guys are right
tomorrow is that like
you can totally make it personal and
call it me people have done it before
and i'm not mad about it i just i don't
i feel it it feeds me
no i gotta say i think bbs has the
lowest of all the dc films on rotten
tomatoes oh i think
a suicide squad might be a little bit
lower like by one point
don't producer lucy if you want to but i
could be wrong
okay um but that's insane to me
regardless of my feelings on batman vs
superman and that's why i'm so happy to
have mike on is because
this is one of those films where my mind
is made up for the most part but i have
questions
i have questions and if these questions
get answered in a certain way there's a
chance that i come out of this episode
feeling different and jacqueline i can
tell you this no person on earth
has seen batman v superman dawn of
justice more
than mike kalinowski he studies these
you do not want to get into a trivia
battle about this movie with this man
he will defeat you and so i'm actually
looking forward to having a conversation
about
some things that i might have issues
with that mike can shed some light on
well i will say this for mike um
you are undecided mike is clearly in the
rotten tomatoes is wrong
i am clearly in the rotten tomatoes is
right
ish i actually rewatched the ultimate
edition last night and although
yes there is i have questions as well i
think mine are more pointed than yours
mark i have some very very specific
questions
however i do think that 28 is a bit
harsh
and not to undo all of the things that
you just said mark about
mike's knowledge but lucy has
unfortunately
proved you wrong because suicide squad
is 26 rotten on the tomato meter making
it i believe
lower sorry but that's okay i'm
knowledgeable about tomato meters
you're knowledgeable about men and caves
we can between the two of us we've got
this
and if we don't got it the guy we're
about to introduce will handle us with
the rest that is tim ryan
he's our review curation manager and
he's going to take us back
to what the critics and the fans were
saying back in 2016 about batman v
superman dawn of justice tim
take it away thanks jaclyn so batman
v superman dawn of justice critics
didn't love this one it's a 28
on the tomato meter with 423 reviews but
it does have a 62
audience score so let's hear from some
of the critics in a rotten review
lou luminik of the new york post wrote
constantly threatening to collapse from
self-seriousness
this epic has way too much of everything
including cgi
and oscar winners up the wazoo in
another rotten review christopher orr of
the atlantic wrote batman
v superman is a tiresome ill-tempered
film and one
too lazy even to earn its dismal outlook
however
in a fresh review kyle anderson of
nerdist wrote go in with realistic
expectations and you'll probably have a
good time
after all it's still a movie where man
gods punch each other
so there were a lot of rotten reviews
for this one and a lot of them were
really
really harsh and even some of the fresh
reviews sort of admitted the film had
some issues
that said it's got a 62 audience score
which
means you know some people in the
audience got their money's worth
and that's batman v superman dawn of
justice back to you jacqueline
ah i loved him i don't get to see him
anymore we used to be in the offices and
i could like go over there and he would
get all animated about this
you know review roger ebert wrote back
in 1992 and
i can't do that anymore but i do miss
him and i think he's having a blast
i i think he's having a blast he's in
his room he gets he's researching he's
got his kid with him he's just he's
having a great time
patriots trying to turn it around in
this season so tim's doing just fine
i i get it i know yeah i definitely
think he's doing fine uh
mike for you though um taking it back to
2016.
maybe was there a scene that like you
loved from the first time you saw it
like
like literally in the theater in that
moment where you just you can't think of
anything else other than this is
happening
oh yes for me uh it's the warehouse
scene towards the end
the batman warehouse fight scene uh
that movie because they showed a little
bit of it in the trailers and i'd seen a
couple scenes and by
this point of the film it's probably
like two and a half hours into the film
and we still have not seen that like
where's the scene where's that fight
scene he was
in uh so when that happened that to me
and there's there's things i i of course
don't like about the movie but for me
that epitomized uh a quintessential
batman of what we had not seen in
previous films because he's been
you know so many films before we still
have never seen him be this ultimate
fighter that he is and that scene
really kind of hammered home of what
batman is as a fighter
you have to take it off ah right
commencing drone mode
thermal imaging is showing me two dozen
hostiles on the third floor
why don't i drop you off on the second
[Music]
i love that call i absolutely love that
call because
that warehouse scene is basically right
after him and superman have their
falling out and then they sort of buddy
up and they realize that we do need to
form a team if we're going to defeat
this monster abomination but we also
have to go save martha that being
clark kent's mom from the neighbor of
nebraska
kansas and so batman's like okay
superman you go do the really hard thing
and start fighting abomination get
warmed up get loose on that
and then i'm gonna go save your mom for
you and
the way that batman storms in there and
we know batman is kids not
killing people and trying to administer
justice and tying them up
some folks died that night in that
warehouse and not a few because batman
comes in there and is just this storming
marauder
devil presence and again this is the
first time
that we've seen ben affleck as batman
and he had a nice workout montage
earlier in the movie we saw some
superhero
stuff but this is lots of shirtless
moments they
for the ladies this is the first time
that in this movie that you're watching
this and you say my god michael keaton
christian bale adam west
look out there's a new guy that is
contending for the ultimate cape and cow
because that scene is so badass i
i will just add this to that one because
although i am not the biggest fan
of the dc live actions as a whole the
one things i will say about dc that i
adore
is all of their animated features as
well as all of their video
games particularly arkham asylum and
when i saw that scene i was like oh they
just did
the like arkham batman and like that's
why this is amazing
and every inch of the stuff that i think
was ripped from either
that dc um comics series or some of the
stuff that they were able to do because
for folks that don't know and i'm just
gonna take a little gamer detour and
just nerd out a bit
that arkham game was like groundbreaking
with the fight style that they were able
to do in that and really show batman
like punching and it was very
like it felt like life-like fights and i
really think that that
like they could lie and say it wasn't
but i feel like those two were like kind
of destined to be mike
am i wrong no you're 100 i mean
i'm i'm with you jacqueline the arkham
games are like that's the superhero gold
standard to me yeah
uh those games and they really did uh
to not to go too geeky but let's do it
um
like because for me like in the comics
there was i remember there's one
issue where he's he's training robin and
then one of their first nights out and
one of his first rules with robin was
there's this warehouse house full of
guys he's like before you go into a
scenario like this you unarm everyone
that you can unarm yeah so
batman taking out all the guns before he
even went into the room
to me is like that's batman he plans
there's 20 30 guys in there and how's he
gonna do this with all machine guns he
takes out the weapons first of all and
then he drops in
well i love that we all could have a
love fest on that one particular scene
before i begin to rip into it but mark
um you're again you're you're straddling
things right now so
so what was the scene for you what what
gave you the uh sensation
yeah besides that warehouse scene where
like mike said
you get in there you disarm all the guns
first i feel like john c reilly and step
brothers where i say
i would have done the same exact thing
now if i go back a little bit further in
this movie one of the scenes in
re-watching it that really stuck out to
me is something that i remember liking
during my initial screening and still to
this day thing holds up brilliantly
is that interaction between bruce and
diana who we
are going to come to find out is wonder
woman and they're
trying to steal the same thing and
they're both sneaking around and they
have that cat burglar vibe and
there's nothing a cat burger can sniff
out quicker than a fellow cat burglar
and so they realize they're going after
the same thing and they
just feeling each other out and they're
just kind of eyeing
and talking and flirting and
out toughing one another and what that
leads us into
is this really cool relationship where
they realize hey i don't know you that
well you don't know me that well but
there's
darker forces out there that we're
probably gonna have to team up at some
point this is what
heroes do they realize that even though
they're used to being on their own and
they're used to independent crime
fighting
they know that there might be a worse
enemy that works out there and so we're
gonna have to team up at some point
i believe mr luther is a photograph that
belongs to me
did you get it if it happens no i didn't
the data you copied is military great
encryption
you know i bet with that dress nine out
of ten men will let you get away with
anything
but you're the 10. no i'm guessing i'm
the first
to see through that babe in the woods
act
you don't know me but i've known a few
of them like
oh i don't think you've ever known a
woman like me and that leads us into
another one of my favorite scenes which
is the quick introduction of all the
other members of the justice league that
we just get teased with and
that was one of the the real exciting
things about this movie is regardless of
how i felt about the finished
product and the narrative that we got is
it walking out of that theater you say
oh boy do we have potential because not
only are bruce and diana awesome
together
i didn't laugh when aquaman showed up i
actually thought
aquaman went from being the nerd
superhero to the guy that
i want to get in the gym so i can
cosplay as at next comic con
it was awesome i'm glad we know it when
we
your plans for the next in-person
comic-con mark i think
folks i'm glad that i got this year off
to give me i needed another
365 days to get those those abs and pecs
in order
you have the time look look at camille
nanjiani it can be done
the gold standard for all comedians
working out right
if you can't get like ripped like that
like he's he's proved you all wrong
um i i think what i think about it it's
great that you guys mentioned the scenes
you did because those were all
definitely ones um that i personally
enjoyed and it was actually interesting
watching it last night the ultimate
edition
i remembered something i loved from the
very first time i saw it and that was
jeremy irons as alfred
like i was actually very disappointed to
know that they were recasting alfred for
this new robert pattinson version i felt
like that was the
best alfred casting ever because like
yes i loved michael caine but he speaks
with a cockney accent like you need a
little poshness for alfred for that to
work no offense
he was great but like it just doesn't
fit with the character and
what i thought was really cool was just
watching their interaction and the scene
that i'm
is specific is very early on when um
they're sort of looking at the newspaper
headlines and they're saying you know
alfred's like the world is changing
and he's really setting the stage for
the crux of the film
which is that the gods have come down to
earth and people hold lightning bolts in
their hand and as alfred sort of breaks
it down for bruce who's still thinking
he can play the same
you know i am dark i am the night
vengeance stuff which is not gonna work
people are flying through the sky and i
loved how he sort of
laid that out for him plainly and their
dynamic is really interesting both with
just how he makes fun of her about diana
both in this film and the later film i
just
really loved all of the stuff that they
did together and yeah i was like more
alfred
this is sad why did we have to do this
to him and i thought was the most
likable
uh that uh ben affleck was is sort of
like bruce wayne which i thought was
really good
you're gonna go to war that son of a
[ __ ] brought the war
to us two years ago
jesus alfred counted dead thousands of
people
what's next williams he has the power to
wipe out the entire human race and if we
believe there's even a one percent
chance that he is our enemy we have to
take it as an
absolute certainty and we have to
destroy him
but he is not our enemy
not today 20 years in gotham alfred
we've seen what promises are worth
how many good guys are left how many
stayed that way
that's one of the things when you
understand why
they didn't want to do a full movie
about batman's backstory again because
we've seen it so much but
when you get an alfred that good and you
get a bruce bats that good
you do kind of want to go back and say i
want to get to know these two a little
bit more before we got thrown into this
but
for all this movie was trying to
accomplish mike i really feel like
it did a service to getting that much
storytelling
complete in a very finite amount of time
even though the ultimate edition is
going to run you about three hours
it's still like we got to see we got to
know batman if you had no idea who
batman was
you still get a pretty good picture
painted of who this fella is
where he came from and why he might feel
so much
animosity be it ego driven or be it all
that crap in the bible
is wrong because these gods are now
coming to earth and
they don't look like the ones that we
read about in mark or luke so
there's a lot going on with that
character and i think ben affleck did a
great job and jeremy irons too
yeah i mean let's just go ahead and get
biblical with it mark let's do it
i used to do a bit i used to do a bit in
in stand-up about that
how around this time this movie was
coming out how i i felt so bad for
batman
not only because he couldn't get a
standalone movie anymore but also
because
he was the guy he was the man on the
block and now all of a sudden
you got a guy who's a god who can talk
to fish
you got a guy who's tech in cyborg is
better than you
you got you got wonder woman who's
another god who
is stronger than you and you got an
alien that people are in love with and
so all of a sudden you went from being
the man to being the guy off the bench
and
it's a tough it's a tough fall for an
ego
it's a tough tumble to take yeah
it well it's one of many tumbles
that the film sort of takes i will say
um mike
i know you love it but i think you admit
it has some warts
so if you had some to call somehow what
would you say or something
i would say if we're going to go warts
this one kind of stands out is the thing
it's there you can't get rid of it
uh it is the jesse eisenberg lex luthor
um now i will say this i'm when it comes
to casting of films i'm never
i always try and give the benefit of the
doubt i always try and
um i don't want to bash it when i cast
an actor or an actress is announced
because you never know what they're
going to do with the role they were
chosen for a reason
and so when of all the casting in this
film i was behind everything i was a big
supporter of affleck from the beginning
um i know there was some kind of
dissension with him but i always liked
affect i like him as daredevil back in
the day um but when when
when um eisenberg was cast that was the
first one i was kind of like oh
hmm okay i kind of think what they're
going to do with it
going more of a mark zuckerberg kind of
this
this tech genius type thing uh i'm not
with you i actually like that
character because of how stupid it is
not because it fits in the movie in any
way shape or form
or is cohesive but jessie is having a
good time
it's sort of like tom hardy and venom i
know you're not in the same movie as
everybody else
but i love what you're doing i want to
go where you are take me where you are
and let's go have a party
boys bruce wayne meets clark kent
i love it i love bringing people
together how are we thanks
hello good hi hello lex it is a pleasure
ow
wow that is a good grip you should not
pick a fight with this person
i've i've logged that criticism at films
before where there's one person who's in
a totally different movie i'm gonna go
john cena in
bumblebee right john cena is in john
cena thinks he's in transformers dark of
the moon when everybody else is like hey
we're kind of trying to make this thing
a little more serious
and this movie did not give me that vibe
as a matter of fact
i liked jesse eisenberg in this as lex
luthor
way more than i remember liking and okay
it i bought into it and i don't know why
mike in his villain genius has been able
to now cast
jaclyn and i as defenders of the film
and now mike is going to say
what he doesn't like about it's all part
of my diabolical
plot well let me all set motion let me
fix that right now because
lord have mercy did i have some problems
with this movie first of all
the fact that the only way we get a
coherent movie is in the three-hour cut
somebody like zack snyder needs an
editor and i think it needs to be a
woman and i'm not trying to say anything
else but every brilliant movie we have
ever seen was shot by a man and cut by a
woman because women could be judicious i
am not kidding sally menken
quentin tarantino marty scorsese's early
films were cut by a woman
thelma like y'all trust it is the facts
it was shot by a man it was cut by a
woman moonlight
shot by a man cut by a woman sorry
that's very interesting that's a hot
that's a hot take because every time a
woman ex
explains to me what she had a dream
about the night before i feel like i
have to edit her
but she's editing your bs this is the
difference
because men no offense thought to be
like pat and oswald did this bit i'm
totally stealing it from him but he's
like men we're just like spray the world
shoot everything because i'm a man and i
have guns
and a woman can be practical she could
say we don't need this
i know you enjoyed spraying your camera
all over it but we need to do
we need to do it does sound a little
like zack snyder it does that yeah
me personally i think that
everything they did with doomsday like
it was a caricature
of what that villain was going to be i
don't care what anyone says about that
lois lane wha what was her purpose y'all
should've just deleted her out of this
movie i know there was rumors about the
fact that she wasn't available as much
time as they would have liked her for
and that's why her
scenes got cut short but like everything
with lois i was like why why is she in
africa what is going on like i was just
like
what is going on with this woman why
she's so superfluous to this film
um and so i had a huge problem with that
and then just the overall
pacing like this man does not get in a
hurry to get anywhere
anywhere except for maybe to bring out
the next movie so
i had a huge problem with that but i
think the biggest problem that a lot of
people had with this movie is the one
that
mark has with this movie and
you know we teased it earlier but we are
here to it's time for the martha
conversation
mark are you ready i'm prepared i've
been prepared for this for a long time
and this is one of those arguments where
i
go into it sort of hoping to lose
because i want someone to convince me
how this
scene which really is the crux of the
movie you have to buy into this
if you're going to buy the rest of the
film now as a viewer
i can step back and say okay i really
want to see batman and superman fight
but it'd also be cool to see them team
up and then have wonder woman there and
have them
all be a squad together and go after a
worse enemy
so i like that but this guy
batman has is dead set and he gives that
great speech to alfred if there's even a
one percent chance
we have to take it as an absolute
certainty and he makes these cool
weapons out of kryptonite and he's got
this kryptonian spear
and he's beating the crap out of
superman it's an awesome fight
it is epic and they're crashing through
walls and floors and ceilings and
eventually batman gets superman down
and superman is weakened by the
kryptonite fart grenade that bruce made
and now it's time it is time to hit the
clutch
shot it is time for bruce wayne to turn
into ray allen
and break some hearts because he's got
that spear and he rams it in
and he's about to do the deed he's about
to end
superman's life and then superman says
save martha
and batman hears that and conveniently
his mom's name was also martha
who died tragically and he says why did
you say that name he has to know this
and
mike i cannot rectify in my head
that this guy has been training for this
one singular mission for this
long and here's his mommy's name
and suddenly is like maybe i got to give
this alien guy a chance after all
how does that sit with you in the movie
is that
is is it a quality of the movie to you
is it something that you're like okay
it's not great but we it's a hurdle to
get over and it's worth getting over
how does it hit mike kalinowski that
film
that moment still resonates with me and
i love it
uh now let me preface this by saying i
think
from a writer's standpoint and i'm not a
writer i think there might have been a
better way
to address the actual wording of it with
martha
like save martha kent i get that he has
to say martha but for me
and and all the talk about batman
killing and this and that in this film
this has been and let me preface this by
saying people say batman doesn't kill
batman absolutely does kill he's killed
in the comics he's worn a gun at one
point
and people would say well that was
adapted and that was changed that's okay
batman changes and it's different for
everybody for you to say it's not
my batman that would be what i think is
better because
batman kills and we've set up this
batman after 20 years this is a batman
that has lost robins
you know he has a great speech with
alfred about how many good guys are left
you know we know that uh there's a
robin's gun we don't know if it's jason
todd or dick grayson
we know he's lost people that are close
to him we know he's got a history and we
do see him killing this is a man that's
lost his way he's not who he was anymore
and in that moment there's this this man
who is giving his life up
an alien who's not even of our world
that would give his life up for
this these people of this world and in
that moment
bruce becomes human again here's an
alien teaching him humanity
that don't worry about me save martha
and it's it is the moment and i know
it's weird that you know he can't say
save martha kent because then that's
defeats the purpose i i think there
could have been something with the
editing and the way he gargles the word
martha and then he says
kent they could have tweaked it a little
bit better and i do see why people have
a problem with it's just the name martha
but for me
here's an alien bringing bruce's
humanity back to him
and that forms the bond and we all talk
about superman and batman are
these these two their friendship is
built you know we don't get that
friendship built over
20 years this was the start of their
friendship um
but that solidifies it and here he is
looking and
you know i might have been you know you
could have done flashbacks through
bruce's head you're having that moment
flush for your eyes of his whole life of
oh my god what have i done
who have i become you know bruce wayne
used to be this man who
never would take a life and he vowed to
never take a life and he was just taking
this life
with no impunctions and to have to be
brought back to that
this guy's dying here in front of him
and there's a woman he loves in front of
him going no
that's his name this is martha this is
his mother's name
i do get why people make the jokes about
it i don't feel that i think it's such a
powerful moment and we needed bruce
wayne mowing people down with machine
guns and
to see what he's becoming he's this this
you know alfred doesn't recognize him
anymore and he doesn't you know alfred
can't talk sen zoom anymore alfred was
always the the jiminy cricket on his
shoulder that doesn't work anymore he's
so far gone
yeah the tension with alfred is
interesting do you bring that up because
i
jack jacqueline i can buy everything
about that scene but
it would i would have to take away one
of my other favorite scenes in the film
is the first time we see bruce in this
movie where he's flying into metropolis
and everybody else is running away
and bruce runs into the smoke and it's
such a this is a superhero moment
and he's doing it because he saw this
alien and again
i'm not saying superman was bad but i'm
saying that from bruce's perspective
there's no other way to look at it this
guy
wrecked his building and decimated his
staff you know and there's like a real
human cost
but yeah it's really interesting and so
he hears
martha and it doesn't matter if he says
martha kent because he doesn't
necessarily know who that is either it's
just that he's
he's got this guy who killed all these
people
who who shortened bruce wayne's
christmas card list
severely and he just hears a name and so
mike has gotten me into the red zone
with this but i just i i don't think
that
that i can i can buy it and what
illuminates it for me
is immediately after he's about to kill
this guy
then they very quickly team up
and and he's like go ahead i'll go save
martha and it's like
i thought the ultimate edition would
give us a little bit more
i don't know explanation as to how they
got to that mental head space
but again it's a movie and i will say
the final fight scene was worth me
getting over because i do enjoy them all
battling
doomsday i i will just say that um
as a writer i want to just say this it's
bad
it's bad writing it's just bad writing
it's a good idea
that is executed poorly it's like you
can hear the pitch it's like and then we
make a big reveal
that both of their mothers and martha
and like all of the beautiful things
that mike said
are in that moment but it was written
stupidly
because there's a 50 50 chance when you
play it the way that they played it
that people are gonna laugh and i
remember people laughing
in that moment like it's supposed to be
this huge like
oh this and people laughed because it
was just like what are you serious
fine damn
name was it telegraphed mike for you was
it
was that scene telegraphed early on when
we do
here because i don't ever remember
knowing that batman's mom's name was
martha
when we find out that her name is martha
early on did you know where we're going
with that
no and i like jack i'm glad you said
that i'm glad being a writer because
like i i
i i'm not a writer so i don't see but i
definitely see that
i know the moment and i know what they
tried to do and it was the wording and
the way in the script
um i don't have an answer for what could
have fixed it
but i don't know if be because i give it
a pass because of the comics that i'm
just so used to
not stuff like this coming but i didn't
see it coming mark to answer your
question um
i i i definitely see them i saw the
intent behind it and everything by that
so
the actual wording and i don't know if
it was cavall's performance in the way
he's being choked with the boot on his
neck
that could have changed a little bit
you know yeah there was i don't know i
don't know there was a way to do it
differently
that was more clever that that got the
moment that you wanted that
i will admit 50 of the people in the
audience felt the way that you felt
i would just say that the way they set
it up you also are risking the other
side and that's why it's something
that's still debated but you're not
alone
that's what you're getting the memes
about it to this day yeah mark hoffmeyer
our researcher gave us this great
article
from uh mike looker where he you know
says maybe the moment is brilliant um
mike i think zack snyder will tell you
the check is in the mail but
i'm glad that he put out such a cogent
uh
theory as to why it's great it's
interesting to
me talking about like the edited version
versus the theatrical version and
this idea that like zack snyder seems to
be best when he's a bit reigned in as he
was in some of his earlier films and as
his success grew
and you can't really tell somebody who's
made as much money as he did for warner
brothers
that he's not going to get final cut but
looking at
the three-hour cut of this and then
knowing you know
industry-wise that he turned in a
four-hour cut of justice league
that was then changed so that we got
what we ended up getting with josh
wheaton who literally like rewrote
half of it so there's just like a lot
that
you wonder is this what we're gonna get
with the
with uh the zack snyder justice league
cut gonna have some of that and there's
gonna be this huge conversation in dc
fandom
maybe they like three hour movies maybe
they like having these like
epic you know long stories of these
characters because they love them so
much
i am not as much about it and you can
count me on that team though
i would be on that team because if you
give me on a marquee batman and superman
are fighting
uh give me a nine hour cut i i wanna
watch
that all day and so jaclyn in the same
way that half your theater
was emotionally moved by the martha
scene at half the theater chuckled
i feel the same way about zack snyder's
filmmaking i think that there's people
out there like you who say
this guy needs to be edited and this
movie didn't need to be more than 90
minutes
and then there's other people who say no
you have to wait until the ultimate
edition
to see zack snyder's true vision and for
this movie i would side with the
ultimate edition
i you you don't get to see this but it's
not like i'm a kid going to a comic book
store and if i don't like this comic
or if it wasn't fulfilling i just wait
until next wednesday when there's a
bunch of new
comics in my box this was the movie and
we're not going to see batman and
superman fight for a long time so i say
blow it out give us all the action
scenes give us all the weird uh the
nightmare batman sequences that we're
not really sure how they make sense but
it's awesome to watch and so i do
appreciate the ultimate edition more
than the theatrical cut because there
was actual content in there that i cared
about
yeah i mean basically the the difference
is the theatrical cut was something like
what two
220 215 somewhere in there and then the
ultimate edition gives us another about
40 some odd minutes
a lot more story it gives lois more to
do
a lot of the things that were cut were
her stuff you
spend a lot more time with clark um
grappling with the reality of his uh
actions
in man of steel so there's a lot more in
the ultimate edition
and some of my favorite portions more
time
inside bathtubs with uh lois
lois in the bathtub which again just
solidifies like that woman had nothing
to do but bathe
um it's a beautiful scene though it's a
good scene
i would point that if couples are
struggling out there i would say go
watch the bathtub scene in the ultimate
edition
yeah and see what you can forge mike
there was a scene that i was watching
and again i'm not sure if it was in the
theatrical cut but
it's right after bruce is having the
batman nightmare
scenario and then flash shows up
from from the uh some sort of flashpoint
magic
was that in the original cut or is that
ultimate edition stuff yeah that was in
the original
too yeah um you know where was i i don't
remember
and i don't know why they didn't put out
the ultimate cut
like because nobody's gonna buy a ticket
for a three-hour movie
a lot of them would have bought a ticket
for that i disagree
wait a before you say that and like i
appreciate that you have an
agent at work in this but i'm gonna tell
you about box office numbers
the more minutes you are over 220 you
are literally knocking millions of
dollars off of your box office potential
i debate that all the time with with on
the shows that i'm on where i
i do understand as like you've got to
get a film under so and so because they
got to show x amount in a theater every
single day
i get that i forgot which film we were
talking i think we were talking about
end game with some people about like
and i was like no they've earned a three
and a half hour film
but then again it's gonna be the biggest
film of all time and some theaters were
only endgame for that entire weekend
because it was so much because you're
cutting down and the time that the
theaters
again yeah we get no but you you make a
great point because a lot of people just
not that they're just unaware of it of
the how the industry works and you have
to hit
certain numbers per day um so
and it wasn't like a a the film bombed
and then his next film was okay just
like we got to recut this down to two
hours yeah this was the
you know they're coming off man of steel
which was like 650 at the box office it
was a good hit for them
so they probably i don't see why they
were like but they probably were like
this can be a big one for us we got to
see as many times as we can get it two
and a half hours and it wasn't just
batman and superman kids
you you get to see wonder woman you get
you got a new way you're cramming a lot
in this one they were they were trying
to get a lot done
and it's really funny yesterday army
hammer uh put up a picture
of the original justice league that was
actually
set forth by warner brothers with um
miller george miller directing and it
was army hammers batman
um it had uh petronas yes dj controller
superman and what's his name adam brody
was the flashlight
was wonder woman yes and it was that was
going to be the justice league and they
were going to start off
the way that they sort of started off
and what's really interesting is when
you go back and look at the history of
warner brothers they have this ip
which is extremely valuable and they've
always had it
and they've always had it and they saw
what marvel was doing
but they were extremely impatient
they they saw what marvel was doing and
they didn't realize that first of all
let's remember the first captain america
movie that was at paramount
that was not all under this disney
banner it came together and coalesced in
a lot of like separate pieces
but they started with standalones and
marvel kind of got over the fact that
like the first hulk was at universal
the first uh captain america was at
paramount so they weren't playing with
all disney money
until they're getting close to the
avengers and so in wb's mind they're
like start with the justice league and
move forward and
i think it just really kind of shows
that they don't i just don't think they
know the
the long game i don't think they just
want to invest in the long game at this
point
i don't know mike what do you no i i
it's funny because i i was talking to
lucy about this it's like
they were doomed to fail what's the
saying you know doom
damned if they do damned if they don't
like yeah if they would have done what
marvel did
done a batman film a one-on-one film
building to a justice league it was like
all the cop bring the mcu blah blah blah
and then they didn't do that and
everyone's like why don't they just do
what the mcu did i remember
at the end of bvs one of the guys i was
with he's like what no no post credits
scene that's what a wasted opportunity
is like that's marvel's thing they're
not setting up the next film
but he was so trained and marvel has
done such a good job of training
audiences
to expect this build shared universe
these post credits the building this
character comes in from this
when you don't get that and i was
thinking like if this film came out
either i'd say
pre-ironman or let's say maybe five
years from now
i think it would be much better received
because snyder had a thing you know his
man of steel was his own thing
from there they're like hey what how can
you build the dc universe off of your
man of steel
and he said okay and he came up with a
five film plan
that was his version of the film it
wasn't direct from the comics it wasn't
like hey we're taking story lines the
character's gonna look like they were in
the comics
i'm doing my own thing and it just was
not right for audiences isn't it
you know love it or hate it that it came
out right around civil war which was
kind of
this watershed moment for the mcu which
was so damn good introducing spider-man
and
they just hit all the right buttons in
him and for a lot of people the
bvs did not hit those buttons at the
same time
it's a poor timing thing it's also that
civil war
sort of did the same thing batman vs
superman did where you took iconic
characters that had not had their
standalone movie to that point
in the mcu with black panther with
spider-man
and they put them in there and they gave
them enough action for us to be like i
need to go see that movie and that movie
and that's the genius to me behind
batman v superman that's why i'll defend
that and as jacqueline knows also defend
justice league
is because i think that if you had done
a standalone movie
of aquaman or the flash or cyborg
possibly even wonder woman before we saw
them
in action at all those movies aren't
doing that well
wonder woman i think would draw at the
box office but not like it did because
we got to see diana kick so much ass
for the last third of batman vs superman
and so i don't i think aquaman was a
joke aquaman was a joke that he was a
he was a standalone movie in entourage
only
and you had to see aquaman before
you you had to get a little bit of proof
before you buy the pudding and i think
that's what
batman v versus superman disagree about
that and i am not a dc fan but if you
would have given me an aquaman movie
a flash movie a wonder woman movie and a
batman movie which is more akin to what
the mcu did because they did hulk
they did captain america they did thor
and they did iron man
then you're fine you're right trying to
pull in cyborg look
we know when t'challa showed up like
let's keep it real we know when these
characters show up
okay they still didn't we just now maybe
in 2021 gonna get a black widow movie we
know how this works
but it could have happened they just
needed to be patient
and i i just think they're looking at
the billions that marvel is making and
they're like look we have these
things we need to get it going and and
that's just what they did
look i think it could have been done
better
and you can fight me if you want believe
the snyder cut is coming so maybe i'll
be proven wrong
i i think also the one thing that dc did
not have was a
a feige uh uh you know a shepherd to do
this i mean this guy has been with the
marvel universe i remember watching some
dvds of like x-men and fantastic four
he's in the background
it these big production meetings just
taking notes he was a part of it
from the beginning and then to take you
know what they did
and i think there was a change after
justice league and everything you know
that's going to be a story for another
time to find out what all happened and
how the oral history of the justice
league i cannot win
when he was finally gone and they
brought in walter hamada who
really kind of seemed to have a love of
this and is now letting filmmakers
do the films without going hey you know
and i'll say this
wonder woman probably my favorite of the
dcu i love that film but i think when
that film was going on because it was
right around suicide squad and bvs but
they didn't touch it they didn't try and
mess with it and
i'm gonna say this i think the heads at
warner bros like you know what it's a
female starring film with the female
director
they weren't worrying about it because
to this day films
led by female directors with female
superheroes didn't do well so i think
the male mentality of the studio
luckily they thought like that because
they left alone and it's
the gold standard of dceu patty jenkins
what she did with that film
that's what it needs to do so i think it
was a happy accident they didn't touch
it try and manipulate the film at all
they were too focused on suicide squad
and we saw what we got with that
you know i mean let's be honest the only
thing that they did they ruined harley
quinn
because marketing that movie's great
that movie is really fun
really great and the just because they
called it birds of prey and didn't want
to just be like
harley quinn how that movie didn't do
banana box office i have no idea because
they called it birds of prey and people
didn't know what it was like they didn't
actually call it
birds of prey they called it birds of
prey and then like 13.
like but the only thing that's showing
up on the marquee is birds of prey which
is why
halfway through the run of the movie
they switched it
yeah you're right you're a hundred
percent right nevertheless it was a
terrible decision because
if i can if i can go back though in time
i
i don't just as a fan i don't want
anything to replace the excitement of
when i was at comic-con and they made
the announcement that the next movie in
the dcu was gonna be batman v
superman even knowing that they might be
force-feeding us a little bit they might
be walking into a trap or biting off
more than they can chew
it felt a lot like the start of a new
football season for me where do i think
washington
in my head is going to win the super
bowl probably not or even get to the
playoffs
but nothing can dampen the enthusiasm
and that comic-con it was actually
during the very short period of time
when schmoe's no
we started a website we were breaking
news and we were one of the first ones
to get that scoop up there and our site
crashed because we didn't have the
bandwidth for all this traffic
and so christian harloff and i were
walking around comic-con panicking about
the site but we're also super excited
because
they showed a teaser that to this day
might be the greatest teaser i've ever
seen yes it's just batman and that armor
and he's looking up and he flashes the
bat signal then who's in this guy's
superman and you get those red eyes and
it's like
jesus i gotta wait a year for this this
is
and i'm getting chills talking about it
so for whatever
issues i have with this movie i still
feel like it brought so much good and it
showed the filmmaking genius
that zack snyder is but i do agree with
jacqueline there there are parts of it
that need to be reeled in not
necessarily
the length of the film but just what
you're showing in that storytelling
what you're trying to get done sometimes
it's not a buffet
comics especially are not a buffet
there's too much
out there and if you fill up your plate
you're gonna make yourself sick
and that's what this movie did great tip
for everyone once cruise ships come back
that's a great tip
they love to throw the food at you stay
away from the carbs don't get full too
just just you know do a little sampling
but i will say this for the for the dc
fans
one they are loyal and they love these
movies and
and in a way that i don't think marvel
fans would have been as loyal
like marvel fans seem like they're that
dude where it's like if you gain 10
pounds he's
he's looking elsewhere like i mean it
really is like they are
not sticking through the thick and thin
tough times
the fact you said that like i just
recently realized there's this hate
online for end game
yeah like this just vehement hate for
ending game i'm like what are you
talking about
i mean like what yeah like like dc fans
are passionate
and their passion is sometimes directed
in ways that i wish they would seek
elsewhere however i will give them this
they are
so incredibly loyal to these characters
and they just want to see them
i think they just want to see them doing
anything but for me my relationship with
dc is somebody like one of the very
first comics i ever picked up was death
in the family
uh that that batman comic i loved batman
definitely animated shows stayed with it
but when they started making the films
especially this last batch when i was a
reporter
to me batman and dc really feels like
the boyfriend
who was great for the first like two
years of your relationship
and then he cheated on you and you just
kept coming back
because like he cheated on me with
batman and robin
and i was like we're done but then he
came back with the dark knight trilogy
and i'm like he loves me and i know that
we're going to be together
and then he slept with my sister when he
gave us suicide squad
you know what i mean like it is just it
is too bad it's such a good analogy
and it's just i i can't but you love him
though you love it i do love him but i'm
just saying man like i can't be with you
i love you but i love me more but i
think i think
i think pattinson's coming with a puppy
at christmas for you i can't
i think he's with a puppy at christmas
coming with that puppy soon
if they get me back in there i just want
all of y'all to be the girlfriends of
mine that'll be like i told you
i told you i told you you're not so good
though told you not to take them back
he's got a butler he's got a great you
can have a whole wing of wayne manor you
don't even need to see
these lives before mark fool me once
fool me 15 times honestly at this point
i can tell you when i saw that that matt
reeves batman trailer
i see bob pattinson and i can call him
bob and
i see a lot of ben affleck in that
warehouse mike yeah
i see a lot of that attitude and i'm
getting i'm getting revved up again he
might be
he might be my boyfriend that keeps
coming back into my life and teasing me
but
i am it's about time to get teased again
even even batman and robin i still find
stuff i love in the future
here we go this is the alfred moments
the clooney alfred moments man
they're great those those moments of the
two of them together
are awesome michael guff great alfred i
will see your alfred and raise you and
alicia silverstone
i got nothing to say i got nothing
before we get out of here mike
uh so so what i mean obviously you love
it
you you you think this movie should be
fresh and i'm guessing all the zach
knight
zack snyder films you pretty much feel
the same way and you are desperately
excited for the snyder cut i'll tell you
this and i've talked about it
god add nausea to people i think people
that love snyder are gonna love his
four-hour cut i think if you don't like
justice league you know or you don't
like bbs you like man of steel you're
not gonna like this far
cut even if you know his entire vision
you're not gonna like it i don't think
we're gonna get more of
snyder uh i'll say this like look at
look we talk about batman we've talked
about x amount of films of his
and how many times we've seen how many
times we see the pearls and the martha
moment being shot
every film is in it i'm sure pattinson
will have it but the fact that snyder
if you watch that film you watch um uh
jeffrey dean morgan at the beginning he
does something that no thomas wayne has
ever done he balls up his fists and
starts charging the guy
so the little things like that in batman
in this film of why i love it he takes
what we know about batman
and flips the dynamic of it and gives it
a fresh light like so little moments
like that with
you know thomas wayne was actively
trying to save his wife's life
and his son whereas before it's like oh
it's okay here's some money no
we're not going to hurt you and this is
a different thomas wayne it says sets up
a different bruce wayne
he goes later in the film where he's
like you know the first generations of
wayne's were hunters that's what we did
um oh yeah i forgot that line i love
that that's the line that bruce gives to
alfred because they they've kind of been
at odds the whole movie and he's about
to go take on superman
and and bruce starts telling this story
and you're like where are you going with
this b we kind of got some stuff to do
and he gets to that point where it's
like the wayne started out as hunters
and then just drops the mic jack when i
got bad news for you i got really bad
news for you
i think i'm getting to fresh with this
now there you go
there you go i got more champ i got more
for you to whisper it to you in your
sleep martha
mar i know and it's tough to rectify
the entire movie martha i apologize to
everyone
the character off of a douche and i
i think martha is is a trash scene
but i i think kalinowski has corrupted
my soul just enough to get me to
french you give it up so mark i'm going
to give another one for you buddy
this again is now towards the end where
we're talking to the film
and i think i've used this line over the
past four years of our
world of what we're dealing with right
now where bruce says that you know
die he's like men are still good we
fight we kill we betray one another but
we can rebuild
we can do better we will we have to that
line of superman what he taught him it's
like
that sets up you know here's this man
and it speaks to us as people like we
are we're terrible to each other we kill
each other we fight but we can be better
we have to be better
and we try you know and say what you
will about a comic book movie though
that just fluff or whatever but
that's what pop that's what culture is
in movies and film it it
speaks to who we are it speaks as a as a
people of what we are
and in that moment bruce wayne was all
of us he was
we are these evil destructive people we
can be but we're also these wonderful
people
that have such a capacity for good and
superman
is that he's you know from man of steel
you know
people you'll be a light to these people
they'll come to you they'll walk in the
sun with you
it's like here's this moment and again
jack and i get it the writing
i wish i had i don't have an answer i
don't know what could have made it
better
um but i just see that and and i think
that's where the film
there's just so much goodness to it and
i'll when we're closing out i'll say
something about this film that i think
will resonate
for future um i just think
it was a different film that people
weren't expecting it wasn't
a comic book strict adaptation and i
think people need to look at it maybe
with a different lens going going okay
this is not
the comics brought to life what the mcu
does this is
these superheroes through a different
lens and maybe that gives people a
different perspective
wow well you're gonna make me one of
these evil people
because i'm gonna just go ahead and say
it i didn't care for the lens
or the framing and you could and you and
you could
stab me in my cold dead heart but i will
not change my mind i was so
no no get this man an editor and maybe
there is a good movie i will give you
this
there is a good movie in there okay but
hey we didn't get it
okay fair enough and i agree with you
jack like you said earlier like
i'm with mark like i can see i'll sit
through a five hour batman film
i will you know in this and there are
films and i'll say this this is not a
film that i put on just to watch like
civil war i'll throw that thing on just
have it on the background i'll turn like
oh that's a great scene i love this part
this is awesome
bvs i don't come off of it feeling like
great after the film it's a dense film
that
i have to sit down and watch but that's
just the type of film it is to me
i want to thank you for that insight and
honestly
you did move me your words did move me
if the move if the film moved me half as
much as your words i wouldn't dislike it
so much
but i agree that rotten tomatoes is
right the movie is rotten
though i wish everyone in it well and i
will be there
on hbo max to watch the snyder cut
because
i live in this world uh mike i'm gonna
any any final thoughts from you on the
film
i mean obviously maybe telling people to
watch it yes i'm gonna say this i've
said this many
times i it's a hill i'm going to die on
forever i get so much crap for it but i
also get a lot of love for it
i think this film batman versus suman
ultimate cut dawn of justice
this is the blade runner of our
generation
if you look at blade runner back in 80
you know with 82 or whatever
that film with it's all different cuts
people are watching that they're like
what is this we're watching what is this
i wanted
han solo after star wars i wanted space
battles and this is one of my
androids and a unicorn what is this
replicants
but look at that film now a classic
so i'm saying 20 30 years from now after
the different cuts are done or whatever
batman vs superman will be looked at
just as great as blade runner is and
it's it's the blade runner of our
generation
saying it right now i've said it before
i'll die on this hill that's a good
yeah i mean you made my face do
something funny mike when you first
dropped the blade runner but look at how
blatant was looked at back then
people walked in expecting indiana jones
in a
in the future and they didn't get that
they got something very different but
you can go back and again blade runner
is not a movie you just put on
on saturday night for kicks while you're
getting ready for your date it's a movie
you sit down and you watch and it's dark
and it's gloomy i just hope batman v
superman isn't such a harbinger of our
future as blade runner
oh god oh god but i'm going fresh
i did jacqueline i am with the audience
on this yeah i'm not saying it's fully
i'm not saying it's it it's got a per
i'm not certifying it as fresh in my
mind but i i think that
batman v superman the ultimate edition
does enough to get me to fresh
the theatrical cut just in the it's
fresh adjacent but this one i'm going to
say
is just over the uh the line for fresh
it broke the plane
you sold out all right i'm wearing the
goggles
i look like kurt rambis i'm just okay
it's okay i
i can i am comfortable enough in my skin
having been a rotten tomatoes employee
for quite a bit now to go ahead and say
i am okay
with calling it uh rotten uh mike
thank you so much for uh chat with us
today
is really fun before you get out of here
uh tell us what you have
going on and where folks can find you
online yes
uh i'm at mike kalinowski that's my
twitter handle i had mike kelowski
underscore after my twitter was
frozen for whatever but at mike
kalinowski that's my twitter my
instagram
i love twitter that's my social media
platform of choice i love interacting
with people there
currently on the sen network doing the
mandalorian review show every friday
morning at 9 30 we hit it fresh right
away
like that spoilers filled i got a book
i'm working on right now
i can't talk about it because the my
publisher won't let me talk
release the title but if anyone knows me
and knows the movies and movies i love
it's all on that kind of vein and as
soon as i can talk about that i will get
it out there and
uh let people know where they can find
it and what it is mike that's very
exciting is there any truth to the rumor
that your twitter froze because you just
kept defending the martha scene over and
over and over again
and twitter's like hey we gotta get we
got we gotta let this guy cool off for a
little bit no sir it was a little little
more political than that
a little bit i think it was the bots i
think batman enlisted the bot
oh mike also since you are a comic book
aficionado and a movie aficionado any
anything you want to recommend to our
audience for them to check out
watch movies yes think yeah there's a
great great tv show that came out
guys almost 10 years ago called call
human target with mark valley
it's based on a dc comics character uh
ran two seasons it was a great show it's
available
it's on all the streaming platforms
right now it's in dc universe and all
their things it's yeah i think it's
might be going to hbo max soon uh that's
a great
great show i'm trying to think of what
else because i
i like all the kind of popular stuff i
wish i gave you guys some kind of
niche thing that i'm watching right now
i'm really watching be yourself
i'm re-watching daredevil that show is
so damn good oh my god
to know what happened with the netflix
netflix marvel stuff and what happened
why that didn't keep going is such a
conundrum but those shows are so damn
good uh human target
trying to think what else oh strike back
if you guys like good action stuff
it's a little bit on the machismo side
and a little kind of you know but if
you're into good action stuff
uh it's called strike back it's five
seasons it was on cinemax and now it's
available on all kind of
amazon prime and stuff like that live
thank you mike this is a good rex
jacqueline
if you uh if you kids out there enjoy
the streaming you know the movie we just
talked about batman v superman you can
get the ultimate cut you can get the
theatrical version one i think is fresh
one i think is rotten on fandango now
and voodoo uh you can follow me
jacqueline at mark ellis live
and if you do so you're probably going
to see me talk about a show that i
co-host called the movie trivia shmodown
and if you check that out
you're probably going to come across a
young man named mike kalinowski
who is one of the most brilliant trivia
minds i have ever come across
my many years and i've seen them all
kids this guy
you put him up there on the mount
rushmore of people who know
comic book films inside and out he
rarely ever misses a question
and if he does it's just a matter of his
brain tooting at the wrong moment
and mike i think that for somebody like
you who's had to study batman v superman
so much and watch that movie on a loop
to study for matches
it gives me that much more credence that
hey if you re-watch the movie that much
and you still
fawn over it like you do that that
speaks to me that that's
that's impressive filmmaking that it's
got that rewatch ability so
i'm happy to hear that if i have to
watch that film again i don't mind it
it's when i have to get stuff like you
know ghost writer spirit of vengeance
swamp thing two when those kind of
things happen i have to re-watch those
over and over again i do it for the love
of
this mowdown i have love for the swamp
thing television show
oh that's gonna say not the film please
okay the show is going on i have love
for the television show
uh mark thank you so much again always
you folks can find me on every social
media platform at that jaclyn because
i'm that girl that talks about movies
and you can hit us up
at rotten tomatoes on all social medias
facebook twitter
instagram let us know how we're doing
share the podcast with your friends
and more importantly please whatever
platform you're listening to this
um please like and subscribe let other
folks know about it and as i said before
this episode was actually given to us by
a fan
i wanna again thank you folks for
sending so much information to our inbox
because
that is how we determine what we're
gonna do next and you can always email
us at
rt is wrong at rottentomatoes.com
lucy is here to listen to your request
thank you guys thanks mike thanks lucy
tim
mark hoffmeyer of course my partner in
crime and all fun things
mr mark ellis i'm jacqueline coley thank
you folks for listening to
rotten tomatoes is wrong and we'll see
you guys next time
you